ministres affaires étrangères de
finlande nous avons une discussion
approfondie nous avons étudié l'ensemble
des aspects des relations russo
finlandaise est aussi l'actualité
internationale et bien entendu des deux
côtés nous sommes tout à fait satisfaite
de voir ses contacts en direct bien que
pendant la période de pandémie nous
n'aimions nous n'aimions n'ayons pas
interrompu ses contacts nous avons pu
nous entretenir par téléphone nous avons
eu des discussions approfondies ont tant
au niveau des ministères que des
parlements que des autorités militaires
les contacts sont maintenus
donc nous avons aussi des contacts
réguliers au niveau des autorités
économiques et commerciales dans le
cadre de nos échanges réguliers et dans
un certain nombre de cas nous avons eu
recours aux technologies de pointe pour
travailler selon les modalités on line
nous avons eu le forum culturel annuel
russophiles filant d'un avec l'ouverture
de relations de liaison ferroviaire
entre saint pétersbourg et helsinki
en décembre dernier nous avons fait ce
liste effet souhaité nous avons fêté des
santons de l'établissement des relations
diplomatiques entre nos deux pays et
nous avons deux présidents se sont
échangé des messages de félicitations à
cette occasion nous avons confirmé notre
volonté de d'encourager les relations
directes entre les milieux d'affaires
des deux pays et notamment autour du
projet stratégique impliquant rosatom
sur la création d'une centrale en
finlande
nous avons discuté des perspectives de
reprise des liaisons touristiques en
pour les citoyens puisque évidemment ces
échanges ont été considérablement
réduits en raison de la pandémie mais ne
nous espérons que ce trafic va reprendre
à l'échelle qu'il était quelques il
avait précédemment
nous avons également abordé les
questions internationales notamment sur
certains conflits et c'est le cas
notamment de la crise interne l'ukraine
mais aussi sur d'autres questions
d'actualité
dans lesquelles la russie et la finlande
agissent de concert pour trouver des
solutions
nous avons des approches tout à fait
d'antiques sur les priorités en ce qui
concerne la coopération sur le
la coopération sur la dimension
septentrionale de l'europe
cette année la russie va donc occuper la
présidence du conseil arctique pour
l'ensemble de la région arctique et au
cours des deux années qui vont venir
nous allons donc assurée tout le travail
de coordination sur cette orientation
importante
nous avons également parlé de notre
coopération au sein de l'onu et de
l'organisation de sécurité en europe
nous avons parlé des différentes mesures
qu'il faudrait prendre pour assurer la
sécurité en europe et favorise une
désescalade détention dans les régions
et à cet égard nous avons soulevé
l'importance de l'initiative du
président soli nist au niveau de la mer
baltique
pour l'instant on n'a pas été réalisé
mais en tout cas on constate en tout cas
que les pays de l'otan ne remplissent
pas toujours les les souhaits qui
avaient été énoncées
nous avons manifesté notre satisfaction
sur les discussions qui ont eu lieu
notamment au parlement finlandais sur la
question de savoir quel est le statut de
la finlande vis à vis de l'otan et nous
considérons que cette volonté de trouver
un facteur de stabilité particulièrement
importante
nous avons également attiré l'attention
sur la proposition qui avait été faite
par la russie dans notre dans nos
discussions avec le temps il y as
presque un bon et qui suppose est
justement de résoudre la question du
branchement des transpondeurs des avions
militaires dans la zone baltique de
façon à et notre volonté de reporter les
exercices militaires à une distance plus
grande des frontières russes et nous
devons donc justement que soit respectée
cette distance pour éviter que les
appareils de l'otan et les appareils de
la marine russe ne se retrouve pas trop
près les uns des autres
ne considérez que nous considérons qu'il
est parti d'un mois pourtant que tous
les pays de l'alliance euro-atlantique
et les pays d'europe centièmes au
principe du de texte final de l'accord
d'helsinki en matière de sécurité et qui
a été plusieurs fois rappelé au plus
haut niveau mais malheureusement nous
voyons que dans la pratique ce n'est pas
toujours respectée et ceci est la cause
principale pour laquelle la l'europe se
trouve aujourd'hui dans une situation de
préoccupation donc monsieur le ministre
a également abordé la question de autour
d'alexis navalni est également à propos
de la l'expulsion de trois diplomates
occidentaux qui avaient participé à des
manifestations de soutien à venir en
russie nous avons exposé les motifs qui
justifient notre position dans cette
question
et dans l'ensemble nous avons encore
rappelé le fait que nous sommes tout à
fait ouverts à discuter de toutes les
questions relatives aux droits de
l'homme ou aux questions des
institutions démocratiques ne vous
pouvez en parler dans une atmosphère de
camaraderie est tout à fait franche dans
le sens nous avons donc des discussions
tout à fait satisfaisante
nous allons encore en parler de façon
poursuivre ses discussions de façon plus
approfondie
durant notre déjeuner de travail je vous
remercie tout d'abord je tiens à
remercier pour l'invitation de venir à
saint pétersbourg à cette réunion
à cette époque
quel travail sont maintenant c'est rare
plaisir de se réunir et bien sûr nous
avons eu des contacts par téléphone
mais pour beaucoup d'autres citoyens de
finlande je connais bien la ville de
saint-pétersbourg par exemple en 1992
nous avons préparés ici ensemble une
grande réunion sur l'environnement et
notre bureau était à l'église de son
mari à saint pétersbourg c'est la maison
de la nature à l'époque ce qui nous
rappelle notre grande langue l'histoire
de nos deux pays bien sûr le rôle clé
d'un mineur relations entre la finlande
de la russie appartient au contact
humain contacts entre les musulmans et
notre frontière la circulation là bas
est très très intense mais maintenant
bien sûr éléments intense mais la
coopération entre nos services
frontaliers et les diplomates fonctionne
et nous espérons que la situation avec
la pandémie permettra dans le meilleur
délai de relancer ses contacts intenses
et transfrontalier qui existait avant ce
matin j'ai visité notre consulat général
à saint pétersbourg j'ai appris que
effectivement c'est la plus grande
fabrique et des visas de schengen en
europe
aujourd'hui nous avons discuté avec un
mistral à blanc lavrov de plusieurs
questions importantes à l'ordre du jour
je tiens à remercier mes sur la preuve
pour ce dialogue franc et ouvert et je
suis sûr que la possibilité d'avoir ce
dialogue en soi est très importante
et aujourd'hui il y a eu des désaccords
sur certaines questions
aujourd'hui nous avons eu un échange de
vues détaillées sur les questions liées
aux relations entre l'union européenne
et la russie ainsi que sur des questions
de la coopération régionale et
internationale
sur la moskova
actuellement les relations entre l'union
européenne et la fédération de russie
traverse une période difficile la
finlande est un des membres de l'union
européenne et bien sûr la position de
l'union européenne est aussi notre
position la position de notre pays nous
nous avons encouragé la visite du
représentant de l'union européenne
monsieur borel en russie et l'annexion
et légitime de la cre unis et la
poursuite du conflit à l'est de
l'ukraine ont engendré les sanctions
imposées par le mineur open contre la
fédération de russie et une autre raison
pour 7 pour ces sanctions a été l
empoisonnement de l'opposant à
l'externat valny car les armes chimiques
interdits le pays membres de l'union
européenne et notamment la finlande hong
kong d'amener
la mise en prison de l'accident vanille
et on insistait sur sa libération la
cour européenne pour les droits de
l'homme
dans la russie est également une partie
a décidé que la condamnation de navalni
étaient légitimes et en justifier nous
avons également abordé les questions
liées aux manifestations de protestation
pacifique et un arrêt des manifestants
et les moments où il y a eu des
obstacles au travail des journalistes
je tiens à souligner que l'union
européenne est un partenaire fiable pour
la fédération de russie ce sont les le
droit international et la démocratie qui
sont à la base de nos activités l'union
européenne est également un grand
partenaire économique et commercial de
la fédération de russie
dans la situation actuelle il ya un
certain nombre de questions on peut
coopérer par exemple il s'agit du
réchauffement climatique
et aujourd'hui nous avons appris de
nouvelles intéressantes concernant
la réunion entre monsieur lafon
messieurs une conversation entre
monsieur lavoie monsieur gary sur le
réchauffement climatique ce sont des
questions qu'il faut régler et cela est
dans l'intérêt de la fédération de
russie tout comme de l'union européenne
de la finlande
notre coopération doit être bien
organisées dans ce domaine
en outre nous avons abordé les questions
liées à la coopération régionale avec
monsieur à bras ouverts ici il ya un
sujet très pertinent c'est la présidence
de la fédération de russie la présidence
du conseil de l'arctique a commencé
par le mois de mai 2021 et l'agenda de
la présidence russe est très chargé il
s'agit du réchauffement climatique des
questions de la protection des mers par
exemple et aussi des questions liées aux
déchets nucléaires qui doivent être
recyclés ainsi que les un certain nombre
d'autres questions la finlande depuis le
mois d'octobre présidera la le conseil
arctique de barents et nous espérons de
coopérer avec la russie dans ce domaine
et la finlande se tient de sa part la
politique de la dimension septentrionale
c'est également très important nous
avons également abordé lors de notre
discussion les questions des droits de
l'homme par exemple la situation avec
les laitues sion avec you read me
trièves liste orient russe et aussi la
situation idée
minorités sexuelles s'est uni en russie
[Musique]
nous avons également abordé la question
de l'ukraine et la finlande participent
à la mission annexe de l'ukraine la
mission de l'osce et eux et il est très
important que les accords de mise que
soient mises en oeuvre ici la russie
joue un rôle important
finalement je soutiens tard et de la
coopération entre la finlande l otan
nous avons des relations de partenariat
depuis l'année 1994 et ce travail
suppose fille dans le nouvel rapport sur
la défense et la sécurité du parlement
notre pays il est constaté une fois de
plus que la finlande 1 apparaît jean le
aucun bloc militaire mais a toujours
cette option de d'adhérer à l'alliance
et continue
de coopérer avec l'alliance nous allons
poursuivre nos échanges au cours de
notre déjeuner de travail
mais on va plutôt se concentrer sur les
questions globales je sais que monsieur
la robe est un grand spécialiste dans un
nouveau domaine
il serait très intéressant de d'écouter
ce qu'ils tirent à propos du moyen
orient la situation en afrique etc
le commerçant à vous la parole
merci messieurs lavrov
votre récente interview a été largement
discutée selon cette interview la russie
après ta à une adresse à ceux ci ses
relations avec l'union européenne et je
réussis une question à mr avis tôt est
ce que vous allez prendre en compte ces
propos de monsieur lavrov
pendant les discussions sur de nouvelles
sanctions avec une europe et au sein de
l'union européenne et
écouter seulement à mi parcours il ya un
musée rodin et amine vestimentaire on
est encore au mieux de la voirie tous
venaient rues de toronto et mines alexis
et l'insee et août à paris stains
culture et ce à tous les concerts de
nikon notamment il répète à nice et user
notamment détaillé
en ce qui concerne mon interview du 11
février
joseph bourrel était venu le 5 février
à son retour il a fait toute une série
de déclarations concernant le fait que
la russie n'a pas justifié des attentes
et que la russie s'éloigne sensiblement
de l'europe
c'est à dire que ce qu'on entendait
c'est que la russie est désespérante et
sous je le rappelle a été prononcée
quelques jours après l'interview
quelques jours avant l'interview que
j'ai fait donc pendant l'interview on
nous pose nous a posé la question est-ce
que vous êtes prêts à une éventuelle
rupture des relations avec le new
hampshire répondu
donc en principe toute personne qui
s'intéresse à la situation en europe
c'est bien depuis longtemps que depuis
de nombreuses années des ruptures ont
lieu dans les relations les relations
sont au plus haut niveau de l'union
européenne
donc c'est une sorte de on a une sorte
de point de virages en 2014 puisque il
ya eu ce coup d'état en ukraine et
l'union européenne a montré son
impuissance pourra faire respecter
l'accord qui avait été conclu la veille
du coup d'état entre l'opposition et les
autorités et la signature qui avaient
été imposées par l'allemagne la france
et la pologne n'a pas été respectée donc
le nom n a pas été capable de faire
respecter ces accords et je pense que
c'est là que l'union européenne a été
humilié
l'appartement est autrement considérant
l'évolution des évènements par la suite
vous la connaissent on a vu que l'union
européenne est resté finalement inactive
face aux attaques qui ont été faites
contre les habitants de la crimée et du
sud-est de l'ukraine de la part de
radicaux et a préféré rejeter la faute
sur les pôles les épaules de la russie
australia
l'union européenne a résolument
détruites tous les mécanismes sans
exception qui existait sur la base des
accords de partenariat et de coopération
en commençant par les sommets et les
rencontres annuelles qui se faisait
entre les commissaires européens et le
gouvernement russes y compris sur les
projets qui conte qui comprenait
différents espaces de coopération les
rencontres sectorielles et l'essentiel
des contacts que nous avions ici et
notamment les séances de partenariat et
de coopération qui avait le chaque année
avec la participation des ministres des
affaires étrangères de la russie et de
reprise le représentant pour les
affaires étrangères de l'union
européenne et on a vu tous les formats
de discussion on qui ont été détruits
parmi ces importations ce secteur est
courte est important c'est que monsieur
skins us et nos contacts avec l'union
européenne comme organisation
aujourd'hui on a un caractère sporadique
soit ce sont des questions distinctes
sans considération systémique sur les
livraisons d'hydrocarbures et donc
l'union européenne est intéressé à ce
qui est des consultations mais fait en
sorte que la responsabilité des
autorités ukrainiennes ne soient pas
assumées
ou alors ce sont des contacts distincts
séparés
contact est depuis de nombreuses années
les contacts entre les ministères des
affaires étrangères et le représentant
des affaires étrangères pour l'union
européenne que ce soit monsieur borel
hausse après au madame guérini qui l'a
précédée
ces contacts n'ont pas lieu de façon
régulière et donc on a eu des
discussions sur le programme nucléaire
iranien ou sur la syrie actuellement
donc nous nous rencontrons d'une fois
sur l'autre en fonction de quelques
intérêts essentiellement de la part de
bruxelles
nous n'imposons pas de discuter sur
toutes les questions qui peuvent
présenter un intérêt mutuel mais en tout
cas les cas qui se suivent et qui
suscite des rencontres c'est difficile
de les qualifier de rang de relations
régulières
nous sommes prêts à discuter de toutes
ces problématiques et encore une fois
dans les cas où cela correspond à
l'intérêt aux intérêts aussi de la
fédération si et qu'il s'agisse de
l'évolution du climat de la défense de
l'environnement nous avons parlé de cela
avec monsieur borel et et s'il ya un
intérêt à coopérer sur ces questions sur
des formats
tous azimuts parce qu'il ya aussi les
conventions sur l'accord de paris sur le
climat il ya le nul bien sûr mais ce
n'est qu'une partie des relations parce
que le la structure formatrice des
relations entre la russie et l'union
européenne n'existe plus en tant que tel
aujourd'hui
et bien sûr on ne peut pas négliger la
négligence grave de l'union européenne
concernant le statut des russophones
dans les pays baltes en ukraine et dans
d'autres pays qui se voit brimés dans
leurs intérêts leurs droits quand des
chaînes de télévision en russe ou quand
tout va des persécutions contre des
journalistes russophone simplement parce
que ils sont journalistes sur le
territoire de l'union européenne et que
l'union européenne
manifeste aucune aucun intérêt sur ces
questions on voit ici non pas le fait
que la russie s'éloigne de l'union
européenne mais au contraire que l'union
européenne s'éloigne de la langue russe
de la culture russe et de tout ce qui a
rapport avec la russie
et par conséquent nous devons être prêts
à toute évolution de la situation
c'est le choix revient à lemieux en
peine si elle veut restaurer ces
relations
et si au contraire elle veut et si elle
veut revenir sur ce qu'elle a fait en
sont les relations ces dernières années
nous sommes tout à fait ouverts à la
discussion
en même temps nous avons aucun problème
sur les relations au sens plein de ce
terme avec un certain nombre de pays de
l'union européenne et je suis là même
avec la plupart des pays européens mais
les relations avec la finlande sont
justement excellent exemple de la façon
dont on peut construire des relations de
systématique sur le respect des intérêts
mutuels et qui se traduit concrètement
sur par des mesures concrètes dans
différents secteurs
de nos relations il ne faut pas
confondre le nez en peine avec l'europe
nous avons beaucoup d'amis en europe
nous ne fuyons pas l'europe
nous allons poursuivre les relations que
nous avons des relations mutuellement
avantageuses avec tous ces pays désolé
d'avoir occupé et en deux temps
donc chez moi d'avoir été si long mais
je pense que la situation était
tellement tendu qu'il était nécessaire
de mettre au point les choses
partout merci pour cette possibilité de
répondre à votre question si on regarde
la situation de la part de l'union
européenne bien sur l'expulsion des
trois diplomates des pays membres de
l'union européenne à l'époque où le
représentant monsieur borel a été en
visite en russie a été très mal reçue
selon nous ces diplomates qui ont été
expulsés
s'occuper des fonctions régulière
conformément à la convention de vienne
sur les relations diplomatiques
maintenant je ne veux pas parler en
détail de l'histoire de l'ukraine et
bien sûr les années dont on parle ce
sont le même année mais nous avons une
attitude différente au développement de
l'ukraine selon nous les événements de
l'année 2014 ont été provoqués par la
volonté sincère des ukrainiens d'avoir
la démocratie et l'état de droit dans
leurs l'union européenne n'a pas
abandonné le cren sur ce plan nous
soutenons le cren pour développer la
société civile à nos peines et l'ukraine
étant des membres du parti
narnia en deux partenaires de l'union
européenne
comme j'ai déjà dit la raison pour
imposer des sanctions de la part de
l'union européenne ont été l'annexion de
la crimée et le soutien apporté aux
séparatistes à l'est de l'ukraine ont
ici les accords de minsk son temps moyen
qui peut être utilisé pour résoudre la
situation
quand on parle de relations entre
l'union européenne et la fédération de
russie il faut toujours comprendre que
la finlande est un pays membre de
l'union européenne
l'union européenne est un grand
partenaire commercial économique de la
fédération de russie et des milliers d
étudiants russes font leurs études sur
le territoire de l'union européenne
je sais que les entreprises européennes
embauche des milliers de citoyens en vue
c'est qu'il y à a beaucoup de projets
communs entre nos sociétés
c'est pourquoi nous croyons très
important de trouver les solutions qui
assureront
en dialogue intense en échange de vues
intense entre l'union européenne et la
russie
simplement je tiens à dire que il n'y a
pas de relation alors qu'il ya des
liaisons des échanges économiques et
commerciaux qui se développent et
notamment à cause des sanctions imposées
par l'union européenne tout cela ne fait
que montrer que la vie continue et que
la rupture
hélas le travail de sape mené
systématiquement contre les relations
que nous avions ne n'a pas d'effet sur
l'attrait que peuvent ressentir tant les
gens que les milieux d'affaires et donc
tout cela n'est pas très important mais
je le répète encore une fois si l'union
européenne est prête à restaurer ce
qu'on appelle réellement des relations
nous sommes nous y sommes prêts
la société finlandaise unis la chaîne
pilote d humilier j'ai une question à
monsieur lavrov
quand ces événements ce qui se passe
avec alexeï navalni et pression des
manifestations manifestation cela a une
influence sur la relation entre l'union
européenne et la russie
et il est très important de trouver un
point de vue commence sur ces questions
là est-ce que cela aura
un impact sur la relation entre la
finlande et la russie et puisque la
finlande est quand même en paix membres
dans les européennes
j'eus une question à monsieur a ravi ce
taux quel message vous vous allez 1
diffusé en union européenne après cette
réunion concernant l'accès navalni en ce
qui concerne les manifestations
illégales à moscou à saint pétersbourg
et dans d'autres villes de russie et
dans lesquels ont participé des
représentants des missions diplomatiques
de pays de l'union européenne nous avons
plusieurs fois rappelé notre position
haut représentant de l'union européenne
la convention de vienne sur les
relations diplomatiques
notre convention bilatérale avec les
représentants de avec ces pays de
l'union peine 10 que ces diplomates
bénéficier de l'immunité à l'exception
des cas quand il pratiquer l'ingérence
dans les affaires intérieures
donc on a eu des exemples très claire de
type d'ingérence qui sont tout à fait
incompatible avec eux une mission
diplomatique
c'est le cas notamment quand il parle
participent à des manifestations
politiques dans le pays
des propos qui roulait moi tu sais si
les organisateurs de ces manifestations
10/10 divers ouvertement sur
l'ordinateur
ils disent que nous savons que nous
devons demander l'autorisation mais
spécialement nous renonçons à demander
l'autorisation
donc à ce moment là donc les diplomates
comptent
il participa à ces manifestations dans
ces conditions alors qu'il ya eu des
décisions de la mairie de moscou
concernant l'interdiction de ces
manifestations notamment pour des
raisons de pandémie et je pense que les
diplomates savez très bien dans quel
cadre ils remplissent leur mission
mais s'il pratiquer l'ingérence dans les
affaires intérieures alors à ce moment
là c'est clair
aux autres sites diplomatique dominique
vlasto rhône qui ont mis les diplomates
de la l'écrasante majorité des pays de
l'union européenne ne sont pas venus se
promener dans les rues comme l'on
formulé les représentants de
l'opposition
en ce qui concerne la question de voir à
quel point cette situation l influence
sur nos relations et si elle aussi à
cette influence je vois que cette
mauvaise influence sur nos relations sur
notre
sur notre coopération sur les
différentes différentes problématiques
ne se manifeste pas particulièrement
oui nous avons entendu ce que nos
collègues finlandais l'ont dit comme
d'autres collègues de l'union européenne
et les apporte toujours cette
appréciation sur les questions qui ont
été abordées et nous comprenons bien que
tout cela est rédigé et écrit au sein de
l'union européenne à bruxelles et fait
l'objet d'un consensus mais nous
entendons cela suffisamment
régulièrement et quasiment mot pour mot
et donc si elle ne telle décision de
l'organisation qui s'appelle l'union
européenne
alors nous comprenons nous l'acceptons
comme tels que c'est et nous nous
donnons notre réponse mais en tout cas
l'essentiel c'est que nous montrons que
l'union européenne s'éloigne de toutes
discussions concrètes sur des faits
établis et qu'elle se contente de lancer
un certain nombre d'accusations à notre
encontre
donc encore une fois cela ne se
manifeste pas du tout sur les
investissements les échanges commerciaux
sur les échanges culturels sur les
échanges en matière scientifique sur le
tourisme etc
or c'est ça qu'il faut à nos citoyens et
non pas les appréciations qui peuvent
être donnés et qui ne sont qu'en fait ce
que des jeux géopolitiques et qui n'ont
pas de relater rapport avec la vie
réelle
c'est aussi parce qu'il était beau et
matin c'est comme ça merci de ma part je
tiens à dire que l'union européenne
n'est pas
incapable il ya vingt sept pays membres
qui veut unir leurs compétences leur
expérience il ya également la commission
européenne et le parlement européen
et c'est comme ça que le travail comment
est effectué
mais avant d'aller ici j'ai eu plusieurs
discussions avec les représentants des
pays européens par exemple avec le
représentant michel borel avec le
ministre la ministre suédoise des
affaires étrangères madame linde et
monsieur heiko maas le ministre allemand
des affaires étrangères ainsi que le
ministre français des affaires
étrangères monsieur le drian
j'ai eu des échanges avec eux et quand
je reviens de ce voyage je vais
transmettre à mes idées mes impressions
je vais partager mes impressions avec
mes collègues
quant à la situation des diplomates il
faut les défendre parce que le travail
est compliqué ils doivent toujours
transmettre les informations les
rapports
sur les manifestations de protestation
sur les fossés juridique il sait leur
fonction son budget de transmettre les
informations à leur gouvernement les
diplomates qu'ils aient travaillé ici et
qui continuent de travailler ici en
russie je suis convaincu que le travail
en conformité avec la convention de
vienne
lagence d'information tu as mariage team
n cotation une question ondes au
ministre à vous savez que la semaine
dernière il ya eu une grande réunion à
minsk
comment pourriez vous quel est votre
révolution de cet événement en principe
ce qui se produit en vélo russie ce sont
les affaires internes à la biélorussie
qui concerne le peuple mais là aussi je
pars du principe que le nu entre l'union
nationale qui avait été établi
avait établi déjà avant les élections
présidentielles et donc il y avait une
initiative de mener une réforme
constitutionnelle c'est tout d'après les
représentants russes qui avaient été
invités par les invités en tant que tout
observateur par les organisateurs
biélorussie l'on dit que cette rencontre
avait été intéressante
vive et je pense que nous avons
aujourd'hui nous devons aujourd'hui
regardez comment les choses vont évoluer
à l'avenir
mais le fait de même qu'une plateforme
est été instauré pour un dialogue
étendue avec l'ensemble des forces
politiques dans une période qui est
difficile pour la belle réussite je
pense que c'est tout à fait positif
il nous souhaitons sincèrement à notre
amis et nos alliés mais la russie de
poursuivre ce processus qui a été lancé
l'élection qui a vu la russie fin d'été
ce n'était pas une réussite je veux dire
que tous les partis tous les deux ce
qu'ils voulaient le faire ne pouvait pas
se présenter à l'élection
parmi ceux qui voulaient le faire
certains ont été en prison et
l'organisation de ces événements
sous cette forme a engendré des
manifestations de protestation qui à
leur tour ont mené à une violence
policière
malheureusement la biélorussie a refusé
de d'assurer l'accès aux observateurs de
l'essieu audi même si la viola russie
est un membre de cette organisation
oui j'ai eu une conversation
téléphonique avec le ministre biélorusse
des affaires étrangères mais je maquille
et je les ai appelés à assurer l'accès
des observateurs à dos les cieux est
aussi la soeur et la participation des
opposants aux élections et bien sûr il
ya aussi un autre problème une partie de
l'opposition à ces gens ont dû quitter
le pays et ils n'ont pas accès à ce
processus
jusqu'à présent nous espérons que en
biélorussie un processus qu'elle sera
lancée dans lequel l'opposition
également pour être inclus et bien sûr
subi a besoin de réformes
le journal de finlande helsinki synovate
le journal finlandais helsingin sur
alger une question je voudrais revenir à
la question sur les relations entre
l'union européenne et la fédération de
russie s étaient en rupture éventuelle
des relations quelles seront les
conséquences d'une telle rupture pour
les relations entre la fédération de
russie est certain nombre des membres de
l'union européenne
alexion et adressée aux deux ministres
je le dis je ne vois aucune de
conséquences pour les relations
bilatérales entre la russie la finlande
en conséquence de la politique adoptée
par l'union européenne depuis sept ans
et j'ai donné des exemples concrets de
destruction systématique de tous les
formats de discussions entre la russie
et l'union européenne mais ça fait
sept ans que nous vivons sans ce
mécanisme qui avaient été
méticuleusement construit élaboré
pendant des années et qui ont été
détruits donc en 2014 comme je le dit et
alors c'est quoi rien il se passe rien
c'est pas notre choix et tendons compte
tenu des relations quotidiennes que nous
avons avec un certain nombre de pays
notamment la finlande à part les
décisions prises collectivement ces
sanctions complètement injustifiée il
n'y a pas de conséquences négatives pour
les relations bilatérales avec un
certain nombre de pays oui il ya une
baisse due
des échanges commerciaux d'une manière
générale mais vous savez que ç'avait été
une préoccupation des milieux d'affaires
allemands qui avaient demandé justement
de ne pas sacrifier les relations
commerciales pour des objectifs
politiques et à l'époque la chancelière
merkel avait dit que non il fallait
punir la russie politiquement
nous comprenons que au sein de l'union
peigne à débloquer discipline et je
comprends que c'est nos relations
peuvent se développer avec ou sans les
sanctions vont encore une fois telle est
la vie là les principes sur lesquels ont
été établis ses relations avec la
fédération de russie
pour l'instant le mans le fait que ces
principes ne soit pas respectée n'a pas
vraiment d'influencé sur les relations
entre la fédération aussi les autres
pays
une existence mclean karr 14% à 4 merci
pour cette question
tout d'abord l'union européenne n'a fait
aucune proposition concernant une
rupture des relations entre la russie et
l'union européenne
quand le représentant de l'union
européenne messieurs borel étaient des
siens en russie en visite
son objectif était d'améliorer les
relations entre l'union européenne et la
russie
quant aux conséquences
un pour moi elle est très difficile même
impossible d'imaginer une union
européenne sans la zone des visas de
schengen et s'il était nécessaire de
déposer une demande séparée pour visiter
chaque pays de l'union européenne cela
serait très difficile d'imaginer une
telle situation et je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec monsieur lavrov
effectivement
c'est dans l'intérêt du des milliers de
faire de l'économie des entreprises
d'avoir de bonnes relations entre
l'union européenne et la russie
merci merci